hey klicks und herr kollege ich habe
zwei fragen habe ich kollege und zwar
meine erste frage ist san diego bei
selfmade gesagt und wenn ich warum und
meine zweite frage ist ob du ein
haustier besitzt weil du verdienst der
immerhin zb z1 dass du pitbull thorsten
so und da wollte ich dich fragen ob du
vielleicht oder hass oder eben so was
okay das war's auch schon
also das ist auf jeden fall einer meiner
besten fans grüßen sich raphael ja du
kennst mich ja über facebook und er ist
einer der größten fans auf jeden fall
wenn du immer waren auf konzerte kommen
wird es auf der tour oder so du bist
herzlich eingeladen ich sitze ich
überall auf gästeliste wo du willst ist
mein freund und ja seine fragen waren
jetzt san diego ob er damit gemeint ist
oder nicht naja ist ja nicht wenn ja
warum nicht san diego machte sein
eigenes business
und daher ist erstmal nicht besser sein
wir haben eine gute zeit gehabt das
album hat sehr viel spaß gemacht haben
sie zusammen gemacht ist unser baby boss
und der homo und ja wie gesagt er ist an
diego absolutes riesentalent er wird
noch kommen er wird noch richtig krass
abräumen dieses jahr nächstes jahr wird
uns gehören
zweite frage haustiere ja raphael ich
sag dir ganz ehrlich ich hatte zwei
katzen gehabt leider
sind sie mir entlaufen
ich weiß nicht warum die sind einfach
abgehauen die fischer ich habe den
nichts getan aber sie sind nicht mehr da
jetzt habe ich keine haustiere mehr
und mehr pech gehabt vielleicht ein
papagei dem bringe ich bei punchlines
bei noch einmal sehen keine ahnung ist
doch zu stressig ein haustier in meiner
position ich bin nie zu hause ich
brauche schon ich vorher schon eine
haushälterin ich wollte mir so eine
mexikanische haushälterin hoch aber es
gibt wenig mexikanerinnen in deutschland
und die polin die klauen mir zu viel
jetzt nicht die polen wieder die sich
angegriffen fühlen und ich mir auf die
fresse hauen wollen ja bleibt mal cool